ross
speaking of meddling i'm curious of you
as a journalist maybe it's a selfish
question on my part by investigating
this phenomenon have you had the
government come to you and tell you to
speak or not speak about certain
subjects have you had your phones tapped
in any have you had your emails
well emails are tapped to some degree
already but
i think you understand what i'm asking
yeah i don't want to sound melodramatic
but
i think any journalist who does the kind
of work that i do i do a lot of national
security a lot of defense and a lot of
intelligence work
i just naturally assume that my phones
are off all the time that somebody's
listening
one of the things that people need to
understand is that signal
which is an app that a lot of people use
and the belief that it's totally and
utterly safe is absolutely compromised
um i know they'll dispute this but uh my
understanding is that the five eyes has
had the capacity to
access the signal encrypted
communication system and probably all
the others for quite a few years
people who are interested in this should
read a
a series of articles about the cia's uh
penetration of a company called crypto
aeg which was a um
a company in western europe i think it
was german or swiss swiss
uh which for years sold some of the best
encryption equipment in the world and it
turned out that it was totally
compromised and the cia had had a back
door into the technology for years
so people like me assume as a matter of
course that our
communications are compromised i i've
learned from
[Music]
people in the intelligence services
about ways to communicate very safely
i mean a few tips if you're not using a
vpn you're insane
and you should use that vpn in
conjunction with
good quality encryption technology
[Music]
i also use
message boards online
in the dark web to communicate with some
of my better sources
but have i had warnings from government
no in fact i've had encouragement i've
had encouragement from people in
both australia's intelligence services
and
enormous encouragement from people in
america
because i think frankly uh what's my
best interpretation of why this has been
kept a secret because it has there's
been a cover-up for years let's be
honest about this i don't know exactly
what they're covering up but they've
been covering stuff up for years
why have they covered it up
i actually suspect it's as simple as
the majority of people who are aware of
the phenomenon inside certainly the five
eyes that's australia new zealand canada
the uk and the us
the majority of people who are aware of
the phenomenon inside the five eyes
aren't briefed into the ultra secret
material
so to them it's a genuine mystery
and the people that i've spoken to in
the main
in the main the people that i've spoken
to at least at the very beginning of my
research
were people who were prepared to
privately acknowledge to me that yes the
phenomenon is real
but with buggered if we can understand
what it is
and uh
you know
i've spoken to people for example in our
intelligence and defense here in
australia who've told me that you know
there are objects mainly orbs but but
also craft routinely seen around some of
our more sensitive defense installations
particularly pine gap which is the
really super secret base in the middle
of australia that we run jointly with
america
and
they've said to me
that frankly their view is the reason
it's not talked about is because
governments are kind of embarrassed
about admitting it
that that gov you know we're spending
billions of dollars a year for national
defense and the protection of our
population i think america has spent
over a trillion dollars since 9 11.
and to what effect if there is this
technology this intelligent technology
operating in our
skies our oceans and our atmosphere as
and our orbit
to what effect is this money being
expended if frankly governments can't
protect the public against whatever it
is or at least inform the public of
whatever it is
so i guess i'm giving you a very
long-winded answer but i want to give
you a a kind of a cultural understanding
of where i sit i think most people that
i've spoken to in defense and
intelligence in agencies that should
know
privately admit to me that they are as
confounded by the mystery as you and i
are
but i have also spoken to people who
privately admit that they know more and
that the us knows a great deal more but
that the united states has a very close
hold on that information
and it's it's more than top secret sci
this is something that is very very
closely guarded
and that the number of people that are
actually briefed into it inside the
military defense intelligence
infrastructure in the united states is
actually very few
it doesn't include presidents and it
doesn't include congress which i find
breathtaking
um so
yeah i mean i i hope that answers your
question
sure you also mentioned you were
encouraged by some of the people in the
government now when i was speaking to
jim i'm not sure if you saw this but i
was speaking with brian keating and tom
delong and jim semivan
i'll link that in the description and in
that conversation jim said when i asked
him how do you distinguish between
psyops or disinformation campaigns and
so on he said that the cia doesn't
conduct disinformation campaigns anymore
it's illegal right
[ __ ]
that's just such a i mean i'm no
disrespect to tom i mean
i'm sorry i'm a keen student of cia mi6
sis and australian disinformation over
the years and one of the things you have
to be wise to as a journalist that
covers intelligence matters is
disinformation is
part and parcel with great respect of
how organizations like the cia operate
and for heaven's sake we need them i
mean we need disinformation
um
i mean the sad fact is that the cia was
a victim of disinformation going into
the iraq war i mean one of the biggest
catastrophes in recent time
was the disinformation that was spun by
ahmed chalabi and the iraqi national
congress to entice america into an
invasion of iraq on the false premise
that there were weapons of mass
destruction
and the
the thing that i don't think has been
adequately explored around the world is
the fact that america itself and britain
and australia were all victims of one of
the most clever disinformation
operations in recent time
so the notion that intelligence services
don't and aren't still using
disinformation to me is incredibly naive
disinformation is how intelligence
operates
and one of the things i'm wise to as a
journalist is
this is why i you know i've had people
tell me for example that there are
craft non-human technology sitting in
warehouses somewhere in america
now
a lot of people in ufology when i say
that they think i'm saying yeah that's
real i believe it's real i don't
i can't nobody should nobody should
believe any of this until they've seen
it with their own eyes and until we've
actually literally kicked the tires of
the tr-3b if it does have tyres but
frankly we we have to be skeptical
because one of the plausible
explanations for me in my mind about why
america might be talking about this
stuff now is because it's worried about
a confrontation with china and maybe
it's trying to send a message to china
that it has some ace in the whole
technology perhaps derived from alien
technology that it's it's capable of
using and pulling out of the barrel if
it needs to in a confrontation
and uh you know frankly people have told
me that is the case but i'm not going to
believe it until i see it because
disinformation is so
so wild uh in intelligence uh you know
i've been liked to so many times by
spies
and as journalists you just you just
have to
walk away because the first thing
they're wanting you to do is get really
excited and go oh wow you know i've been
told this by a real spy and i can
remember very early on in my career when
i did meet my first people who were
working in intelligence i was actually
based in southeast asia and
i met a cia station chief in a certain
asian country
and i was flattered to be a young
freelance journalist and being taken out
for a lunch in a restaurant i couldn't
afford by
a guy who i knew was agency
and then i realized because i'd been in
possession of
information the week before i was being
lied to and he wanted me to push a
particular line to support a a
particular opposition group in a
particular company country
and you realize that in the moment while
you were speaking with them i did and i
realized i was being manipulated and and
that this is something we all have to be
wise to in ufology i mean it may very
well still be and i really hope this is
the case if this is true
it may very well still be that america
really does have anti-gravity technology
you know maybe they've developed this on
their own and maybe it's got nothing at
all to do with aliens and maybe there's
been a clever disinformation program
uh to try and spread the
the uh
the notion around the world that america
is invincible because uh
it's somehow got alien technology
i mean i i just don't know
but i think we should really keep an
open mind i mean i i
i was amused i got a uh uh bollocksing
from some
dweeb
debunker the other day who said i
believe in aliens and i believe in ufos
i don't necessarily what i'm doing is
i'm exploring the mystery which is what
journalists should be doing
and there's a fundamental
misunderstanding here i think this is
one of the things that has scared
journalists off
because
there's a tendency i think for people to
assume that
uh because i'm engaging with the subject
matter and taking it seriously
and i do think it should be taken
seriously that i believe credulously
everything that everybody says
i'm sorry but i i don't and i don't
think we should
do you think part of the reason for this
ridicule this jibing from
large media organizations against
publishing anything related to ufos is
related to chomsky's manufacturing
consent there's this relationship
between the media and the government a
symbiotic or you can see it as parasitic
look i've been in um on completely
unrelated issues i've been in editor's
offices
in news media organizations when i'm in
possession of highly sensitive
information i i once did a story
for one of australia's top public
affairs programs called four corners on
the public broadcast at the abc and
by complete chance there was a lot of
unhappiness inside our equivalent of the
cia asus the australian secret
intelligence service
and a number of
yeah and a number of australian spies
went public with me on national
television
and one of the things they talked about
was
favors that we would do plausibly
deniable favors that we would do for
either the brits or the americans which
gave the brits
plausible deniability or the americans
plausible liability
in the event that anyone got caught
or in the event that the operation
became public
and a lot of this involved bugging of
warsaw pact embassies during the cold
war you know if if you wanted a bug
planted in the embassy of the polish
republic uh
you know during the cold war you got the
aussies or the kiwis to do it or the
canadians funnily enough your crc was
very involved
and so the the junior cousins in the
five eyes alliance were basically used
as um
stooges to to go around doing plausibly
deniable favors and i can remember when
we
did that story we actually edited it
off-site because we were aware that
there were people inside the public
broadcaster who probably did report back
to the security services what was coming
up on programs like ours so we kept it
off the books and we kept it super super
confidential
and then in the wake of the program one
of the things that we revealed for
example was that um and i still to this
day i find it amazing because
we were sending our tech ops boys guys
who bugged rooms with highly
sophisticated bugs
to kuwait at the end of the 1991 gulf
war
to bug
kuwaiti government officers so that
british government companies could win
contracts in kuwait against australian
companies
and so these spies were saying to me why
are we doing this you know we're being
paid money by
britain to bug kuwait government
officers without the knowledge of
australian spy masters and these
plausibly deniable favors are being done
in such a way that they're actually
competing against australian companies
for the same contracts that are being
awarded
and another thing that was happening was
that in the period prior to the handover
in hong kong
you know incredibly sensitive um
negotiations were going on between the
british held hong kong and the chinese
government and there were chinese
government offices in hong kong
and the the british wanted to know what
the chinese negotiating position was and
so
they planted bugs in the chinese
government's offices in hong kong
and the people who did that were
australians and we revealed that on this
program
and i can remember oh my god the
pressure we came under uh as a tv
network especially because we were
government-owned broadcaster
i thought for a while i was going to go
to jail because
you know you know we were revealing
national secrets and we'd essentially
encouraged people who were under a
security oath to reveal what they knew
and the the nice thing about it was uh
i'm sure they'd still dispute this to
this day but there were reforms made in
the accountability procedures of the
intelligence services to improve
themselves as a result of what we
revealed and it was a good healthy purge
frankly
but what it taught me was the
the level of undisclosed communication
that occurs between government and a
news organization even a public
broadcaster like the abc in australia or
your cbc in canada
there are informal chats there are
informal relationships and
it's
i'm sure there is surveillance of
journalists in this country i've had
reason to believe over the years that
yes i am being
tapped from time to time i often do
sensitive investigations that
upset governments and i guess i just
take it for granted that they're going
to monitor me
and one of the things that i'm agonized
about is making sure i protect sources
this is one of the big problems for me
when i was writing my my book
you know you you agonise about making
sure that if you're going to approach
somebody and invite them to give
information
you know you need to be able to protect
them you have an ethical responsibility
to protect them
and
i've worked out
ways of doing this in the course of my
research for the book that
i hope have protected the
confidentiality of some of my more
sensitive sources
but um
yes
there is
a nexus between media organizations and
government
when it comes to intelligence related
matters
that makes it very very difficult for me
to say that we are absolutely free
and i've seen compromises made inside
organizations when we've got
big stories which i find kind of
puzzling and irrational and it wreaks to
me that somebody's ahead of me i had an
incident once where i was investigating
um
uh
what are called disruption operations
there were refugees coming on boats from
indonesia across to australia
and i stumbled by complete chance across
a people-smuggling disruption operation
being run by
i thought
federal police
and it was done in conjunction with
members of our defence forces
and it was only belatedly that i
discovered that it was being done
also in conjunction with our isis uh
secret intelligence service and you know
there was some pretty pretty grubby
things being done to stop boats from
getting to australia
to disrupt people smuggling operations
and that's the scariest i've ever been
in my career
when i think one morning i came into my
office early and
i turned on my computer it had just been
in sleep mode and i suddenly realized
that the cursor on my screen
was moving through files
and i wasn't touching it
and
more importantly whoever the person was
when i did take control of the cursor
in the two or three minutes before they
realized that they'd been compromised
i realized that whoever they were had
super user status they were logged into
my system as a super user and i could
get into anywhere on the network into
places that i couldn't normally get into
and i still remember i rang the it
department and i said
um
guys are you in my computer and they go
no and i said
i've got this
weird thing where the curse is moving on
its own accord and they told me to check
your mouse you know all these silly
things turn your computer on again and
off again
and then um and then i said yeah but i
can get into
x-file
and i didn't say i'm not saying here
what that file was but suffice to say
the network at the time that i the
network that i worked for at the time
was owned by a billionaire called kerry
packer and i realized that not only did
i get into all of the files in the news
network i could also get into all of the
files in his business network
and i remember i sent this to the it guy
and i could hear him running down the
corridor towards my office and then both
of us watched as
this cursor moved across my screen
and then eventually just disappeared
and so somebody was on my computer and
it's the one time i've been aware as a
journalist that somebody was actually
accessing my material and i can tell you
i was scared it was a really scary time
because
you know you realize that when the
forces of the state are deployed
on intelligence matters there's a degree
of ruthlessness and a degree of
willingness to break laws
to act unethically and improperly
because they are sanctioned to break
laws intelligence services are allowed
to do things that other sections of the
government aren't allowed to do
and um
it scared me it scared me as a
journalist and for a while there you
know i stayed away from the whole
subject matter because it was quite
intimidating
the funny thing is that with the
phenomenon with ufos uaps
when i've
engaged with people at a senior level in
government and after
a fair
period of chatting about other things i
introduced the subject of uaps
there's two things i expect the first is
ridicule you know laughter
and the second is a complete reluctance
to engage
and you know what neither has happened
i've been quite surprised i've spoken to
ministers and former ministers in our
government
i've spoken to people in our
intelligence and defence services
and when i raise the subject of
anomalous phenomena
they're immediately engaged
and it might be
exactly and it made me realize as a
journalist how badly we've dropped the
ball on this because
there was talking about disinformation
there was a very deliberate
disinformation program instituted by
particularly the cia in the 1960s and
the 1970s and for all i know it might
have been for quite notable reasons
because apparently
especially during project blue book they
were just getting swamped all of the
different agencies that were responsible
for monitoring foreign
incursions into america were getting
swamped with these sightings of
anomalous objects and and you can see in
the paperwork that there was a growing
concern that they weren't able to get on
top of
in the event of a a soviet attack they
wouldn't be able to get on top of um
which warnings were legitimate which
warnings were just this weird anomalous
phenomena that nobody really wanted to
talk about
and uh
i can sort of understand why they wanted
to shut it down to me that's a
semi-plausible reason and it's
interesting because when i when i have
engaged with people about this in um
government
i've actually been very pleasantly
surprised and and it's why as a
journalist i feel motivated to continue
because
there is a uh
a willingness to accept that yes this is
a legitimate subject for investigation
and yes uh friends the americans are
probably hiding something from us we
accept that roscoe but that's pretty but
pretty much parcel and parcel of the
five eyes yes we're cleared into the
intelligence that goes through the um
the sharing agreements under the five
eyes agreement but we're very very well
aware that the americans are always
working on things in private aerospace
and new defense technologies that we're
not always immediately read into
and i think a lot of them assume that
the objects that they're seeing are
black american technology
but they're definitely seeing things
what makes you think that your computer
is safe when you're using a vpn or on
the dark web if they can access
your computer and perhaps screen capture
even take keyboard logs
one of the things i regularly do and
i've been doing this for a while and
anybody can do this is
you can download some pretty good
virus trojan checking software from a
company called imazing
who um
in particular they've been able to
detect the is it nro pegasus software
which is this really intrusive software
that's been used
very aggressively against journalists
including sadly the guy who was
chainsawed to pieces by the saudis in
turkey
you know there's been
increasingly there's been misuse of
intelligence related technologies
particularly those built by the israelis
who are pretty ruthless in this regard
um
one of the things i've done a story
about you can actually i think you can
find this on the web when i was at 60
minutes australia
i did a story that actually cbs 60
minutes picked up as well on the
ss7 the signaling system 7
system that operates behind mobile phone
telephony which essentially leaves a
back door in all mobile phones
these mobile phones that are so
ubiquitous that we use around the world
now without even thinking
they are
wide open
to tapping
wide open it's such a huge hole and it's
never been fixed because to fix it you
would actually need to change the whole
architecture of mobile phone
telephony and um i think it's really
important that people know this because
i assume as a matter of course
that all communications are compromised
i
i use
communications systems that
to a lot of people
would look insane
[Music]
to protect the security of some of my
more sensitive contacts
and that literally involves
both of us logging on with a vpn
and
tor
software
going into the dark web and accessing a
place in the dark where we essentially
leave messages for each other
that's about the only way a virtual dead
letterbox that i can think of of coming
anywhere near
being able to
protect the confidentiality of a secure
source
and i'll go to those steps i'll go to
those measures and i've warned i've done
speeches where i've talked about how
wide open mobile phone telephony is and
i see
i was shortly before the lockdown was
instituted here in australia i had lunch
with a federal minister in our
government who's in a very sensitive
portfolio
and he he was taking phone calls from
his staff on his normal mobile and i
said don't you have an encrypted phone
and he went rf effing [ __ ] you know
he says bloody things let us slow things
down and you can't hear you know and i
said yep you realize how wide open these
phones are and he went yeah yeah that's
what asd tells me all the time and asd
is the australian signals director
they're the people that
um
they do the backing with the national
security agency as part of the five eyes
but they are also responsible for
communications
infrastructure security in this country
and
you know i know that ministers are
warned all the time not to use mobile
phones but what they don't realize and i
i emulated this in a program where i was
in london
and a bunch of hackers in germany all
i'd done was give them my mobile
and i was in london and i said i'm going
to be having a phone call with a federal
politician in canberra in australia at 7
p.m london time
can you hack me
and these german hackers from the chaos
computer club
working with a german company that
with legal authorization from the german
government we're using a ss7 portal
which is a portal that opens on the
internet to give you access to mobile
phone telephony
they were able to hack my phone call
by only knowing my phone number
because once they had my phone number
they were able to get my ime code once
they had my ime code they were then able
to patch into my phone call
using this
signaling system 7 backdoor messaging
channel that's used for mobile phone
telephony
and i really think this is important and
i'm sorry if i'm sounding like a nerd
for a moment but if anybody wants to see
my story about this i'm pretty sure it's
on the web just google ross culture
mobile phone telephony 60 minutes
australia
it is an absolute outrage that the
communications companies haven't patched
up these holes and i always laugh when
you read apple giving assurances that
their phones have been made so more
secure or
where you read people from different
encryption companies talking about how
safe their phones are because they've
got encryption and you know
various levels of
245-bit encryption or whatever the
reality is that if you have the back
door that exists in mobile phone
telephony mobile phones are
wide open all governments know this and
all spy organizations know this
and a lot of private corporations that
sell data know this
and one of the things i did as part of
my research was i i
approached
companies in the us that freely sell
this technology they offer it for a lot
of money to anybody prepared to pay
and you can literally listen in i could
if i wanted to listen to all of your
phone calls kurt and i had the money i
could do it tomorrow
and it doesn't matter what you put on
your phone
and so people have got to stop thinking
that communications are in any way safe
and i say this to journalists all the
time i occasionally teach at journalism
schools and
i say to students you know you guys
really need to understand the importance
of protecting sources
and there's always a kind of a
nervousness about it because for
millennials this is how they communicate
this is how they engage this is how they
engage with culture
and what we don't realize is
how much we've given away as a result of
having this easy communication access
and what it's doing to investigative
journalism because
i assume as a matter of course that if
i'm communicating on a mobile phone
any communication is being monitored and
listened to
does that apply to if you're browsing or
if you're going on youtube or messaging
over a certain app
or is it only when you call someone
uh it's
if you're using your mobile phone either
on the web or as a communication tool
they can they can track you
um there's no problem it's very very
easy to get hold of anything any data
any voice message any data any anything
that's going over your phone if you're
using your phone
um
when it comes to say using your pc or
your apple laptop to
browse the internet i mean sure you
should use a vpn and i use tor a lot for
confidential communications with sources
and for searches where i don't want
people to know what i'm searching
there's a great search engine called
duckduckgo which is an anonymized search
engine but even then you should be using
that in conjunction with tor
and you should be updating the latest
versions of tor
[Laughter]
i'm i'm also
i used for years i think called pgp
pretty good privacy which was an
encrypted um
uh system and if people look they'll
find there are very similar systems like
that there are that are commercially
available and
again because of crypto ag which i told
you about earlier i assume that all of
these have got backdoors in them and the
determined state
aggressor can access any communications
it wants to
i mean there are trojans that can be
inserted on any mobile phone
simply by you receiving that trojan you
don't even have to click on it
so
frankly
you know if somebody wants to hack you
they can hack you uh but
am i really that important
you